ciao a tutti ragazzi non eccesso del
treno ok ciao puntato il video che state
per vedere in treno e mi sono accorto
che non ha fatto la intro quindi la
intro di questo video la faccio al cesso
ho voluto fare un video stanco ma strano
k parte il processo come boe mostra voi
sapete che io nel tempo libero gioco con
i miei amici e ai videogames c'è anche
senza registrare ciò che amo sacco a
rocket league con il tempo a rocket
league se un diventati abbastanza
recenti mettiamo dove mettiamo iniziato
ad iscriversi a dei tornelli
ci siamo beccati contro i primi al mondo
di rocket league c'è una squadra che tra
i primi al mondo io che devo quindi
campioni del mondo di rho gatling ed è
stato un genocidio ma serio voi non
potete capire quanto ci hanno fatto il
culo dovete vedere buona visione
vai tu dai vinciamola questa partita
vinciamola è fatta lo stesso fede che fu
quasi tutto storto dentro mi aspettavo
di partire subito
l'effetto non è male invece di due
secondi ci hanno messi sorse ma perché
lo vincono nettamente ma cos'è per te la
togli la volta mi sento fragile come
aver scartato del piero che avevamo è
arrivato tutto storia va bene ed io io
l'ho tolta rimuovo sono forte voglia
aspetta sembriamo l'edificio gigi
zuccherata maniera separata
ora che fosse statali fosse stata una
partita normale l'avremo l'avremo
stravinta questa è perché mica sta
facendo dei tiri incredibili
vabbè gigio io no è stata proprio tolta
gli 80 però aspetta uno presa io l'ho
preso io non lui sono più forte io mai e
luca bravissimo luca no vai di volla il
quale vuole ma tu che cazzo stavano
facendo questi gli anni plauso non è che
vi è una foca massimo tutti cazzuti
arrivano ha tirato da lee don joo donne
volta togliendo basta
matera vecchia perché siamo noi
dai che segniamo noi non cercate a terra
[ __ ] era buona festa abbiamo
pareggiato quindi gigi gigi now we
strawinsky quello di chi è rimasto
ferito
vai vai vai vai dai dai dai dai
luca esci dal in ogni scontata la forte
gli open esplodono tentativi bravissimo
tuca ricaricati di brutto però ora 10
siamo forti noi siamo più forti
stiamo vincendo con i professionisti
nessun problema
uno a zero e andiamo i piselli volanti 9
è fatta parola significa che sei salvato
dai ragazzi resistiamo
lì ci siamo per 4 minuti 12 so che ce la
facciamo noi
11 non me l'aspettavo mike harris che ha
segnato di voi minchia luca insegnato
che proverei segnare una la juventus dio
capito no sembra che il nostro vantaggio
durato qualche 20 secondi siamo stati
fortissimi venti secondi
con il 14 è buono ma anche sul veramente
bello nomi sentitamente la mia figlia
bello bello che avevo fatto una trovata
che da allora grandissimo luca bastardo
di merda ma vaffan cuore va vai luca mai
bravo guarda che è stato fatto
ti è piaciuta perché cross cos'è mappe
ma cos'ha fatto
bello ma che gol
ma cos'è ma cos'è erano davvero ne fossi
vi spingete aiuto al taglio tolta non
segneranno mai fatto meglio dove ero a
caso di gara dov'ero io avevo in comb
andamento che si son piovute addosso 22
persone come cadute persone dal cielo
con le palle mi ha fatto scemo giudizio
dai per quanto storto glie l'ho tirata
orali proviamoci
lo sapevo che c'è di tutto dai giornali
non è entrata a [ __ ] affitto ce
l'abbiamo l'altra va bene accettazione
lei che il messaggio porca [ __ ] non
glie l'ho tolta l'ho tolta poi vabbè mi
va bene uno non creata non è forte punto
di forza dai dai dai bravissimi dentro
tutto in mezzo se riesco a [ __ ] va
dai danni dai dai dai dai dai dai dai
danni vengono i nostri prezzi import
arabo la palabra carte peccato che sarò
un minuto senza prendere in coma è un
record incredibile uno scarto beni per
lei
se si come no va bene sono 120 c'erano
tre però ok dai dai toni la togli a
toglier no
e va bene nono turno però l'ho presa io
ero e spazzola danni perché se non sai
come si sa cosa stavolta no il turbo e
scemo così entrata fatto che culo
assoluta zero è questa stai zitto perché
lo devi dire che un ora ma che rimbalzi
del bene su quante parole dello sciopero
è vecchia orwell già che non segno
madonna vai aveva il bravissimo dai ha
avuto in mezzo
malissimo o troppo e la tolgo bravissimi
dai dai dai dai spingenti ragazzi
mario
parla
dai che buona
ok da questo punto in poi non c'è più un
cazzo perché la mia reaction dopo aver
sbagliato un gol a porta vuota è stata
quella di lanciare il microfono e si è
scollegato tutto insomma perso i file
che siccome non c'è il finale della
partita
lo dico io come finita abbiamo vinto
abbiamo vinto tutto quanto siamo
arrivati primi al torneo
prima di concludere volevo dirvi ragazzi
di oggi parte la prima puntata di social
face che sarà in onda punto martedì e il
giovedì su skyuno ovviamente con che vi
faccio vedere la prova perché è troppo
fegato anno milioni di views il loro
video sono i più cliccati sono le
webster più seguite di un'italia sky uno
le ha riunite per sfide che entreranno
nella storia sembra uno dei gironi
dell'inferno dice comanda chi perde
vuole potrà vincere al mare i migliori
talenti della rete solo in tv in prima
visione in esclusiva social face mio da
giovedì 5 maggio alle 19 e 40 solo su
sky uno
e cita ragazzi dal cesso del treno io
direi che posso concludere
spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi se
pensate che non abbiamo vinto lasciato
non mi piace perché noi abbiamo vinto
c'è va beh anche la pagina di facebook
come diviso tra te nel cesso del treno
soluzione si descrive decidiamolo subito